a lot of people are very happy ladies
and gentlemen these Confederate statues
are coming down a lot of people happy
yeah someone who's not happy president
Trump did you hear about this
yeah president Trump tweeted this
morning that he's sad over the removal
of our beautiful statues now of course
of course
Trump may just be sticking up for his
fellow bronze colored symbols of hate so
it's possible and maybe maybe their
removal yeah they're taking bronze
colored things away I don't like that I
get nervous yeah it's true in a tweet
this morning President Trump called
Confederate statues beautiful that's
right people were shot because it's the
first time Trump has complimented
anything that's over 40 years old
generally at a nice rack
[Laughter]
and on the bright side things seems to
have calmed down with North Korea yeah
yeah that's nice yeah
don't woo things calming down get them
all excited again president President
Trump said that North Korean leader Kim
Jong Un's choice to not attack Guam was
a wise and well reasoned decision that's
what he said yeah and truck Trump said
someday I'm gonna make one of those I
love this story ladies and gentlemen
this is true some white supremacists are
now upset because they're taking DNA
tests and discovering their part black
and discovering their part black and
guess what you know who's even more
upset their black ancestors
yeah how did we end up with Cletus over
here what are you doing with those jeans
[Laughter]
a lot of people turning against Trump
not happy with him right now the
American Cancer Society has decided not
to host its charity event at Trump's
resort Mara Lago yeah yeah you know it's
not a good sign for Trump when he's
considered too toxic for cancer cancers
like who else you got no cancer no
Hillary Clinton in the news Hillary
Clinton is coming out with a book called
what happened yeah
out of habit Bill Clinton immediately
came out with his own book called baby I
can explain
[Applause]
he's come out with that book 700 times
you